welcome to the prosthetic art challenge
for cicchitto shadows die twice
the wolf's prosthetic arm is at the very
core of sequitos gameplay swapping
between attachments allows you to throw
shooter guns blast flame smash defenses
hurl spears attached to rope grapple
stun and you can even con just steal
umbrellas out of thin air but I want
more come up with an original prosthetic
arm attachment design it and tell us how
it works and you'll go into the running
to earn a piece of 1500 US dollars as
well as a portfolio shout outs on this
channel if you really want a boost to
your social media or your Commission's
I've arranged it this way because I want
almost every serious entrant to receive
something in return
artists deserve to be paid for their
work and any exposure that I can give
you is just the cherry on top
furthermore I have a bunch of Humble
Bundle keys to give to the runners-up
so most of you will get a bunch of games
for participating and there's also a
mystery prize that you are eligible for
if you send in a copy of your work
within two weeks it doesn't have to be
the final version just get in a draft
before two weeks and you'll be eligible
for the mystery prize the competition
itself will end in exactly one month on
the 8th of March so make sure you get in
your final submission before then to
assist with your design and to help us
receive a bit of consistency in the
designs we've designed a template that I
recommend you follow it includes an
official piece of reference art so you
can see everything about this arm
there's a space below it where I want
you to describe your weapon in text and
there are three angles of the arm that I
recommend you fade out and draw over now
while it's mandatory that you try to
fill out the written section nothing
else on this page is mandatory if you
want to draw over one of these arm
templates that's fine if you want to
draw over all three of these angles and
get a bunch of angles on your weapon go
for it if you really want to you don't
have to use these arm angle
at all you can start from scratch just
imagine you were designing something for
from software's animation and gameplay
team all they would want and all I want
is to understand your design and how it
functions speaking your function let's
go over the written section if I was
describing a weapon called the loaded
axe prosthetic I would say that it's a
weapon designed to crush your enemies
defenses it's our two performs a
vertical smash attack and it's follow-up
performs a double bladed slice including
the katana most follow-up attacks seem
to use the katana in some way and
finally you can be as realistic or
outlandish with your design as you want
some of you might want to design a bow
prosthetic something very believable and
some of you might decide to strap the
moonlight greatsword to sequitos arm
that's fine too from software have
always been realistic and ridiculous at
the same time so you can be to again
entries close exactly one month from now
on the 8th of March please submit your
entries to cicchitto challenge at
gmail.com make sure you include your
artist portfolio your social media and
your paypal address in the event that
you win all of this will be written in
the description considering I'm giving
up quite a lot of prizes please don't
feel discouraged from entering you'd be
surprised at how few people do enter
these competitions and no matter your
skill level I'll appreciate it a ton so
will everyone in the comment section
when we show off your art if you have
any questions let me know and remember
if you submit a draft or the final
version within 2 weeks then you're
eligible for the mystery prize you'll
understand what it is when I tell you
about it so please go for it good luck
thank you so much for participating if
you do and remember the game's tagline
kill ingeniously I'll see you next time